Hey guys julia here for DNews
Most people when they hear the word tumor
think CANCER but that’s not always the case.
There are a lot of different types of tumors,
or neoplasms as they’re called by medical
professionals.
The two main types, benign, which means it
stays as it is, and doesn’t change and malignant,
which signals something bad, like cancer,
which means it can spread.
There’s a lot of tumor terminology.
Names of tumors most often come from where
they grow.
Like Adenomas come from epithelial tissue,
which is a thin layer or membrane that surrounds
your organs.
Fibroids grow on fibrous or connective tissue.
Fibroma durum (hard fibroma) is a common type,
they’re those skin tags you get on your
neck or armpit.
Hemangiomas are more like those strawberry
birthmarks, they are just a collection of
too many blood cells in one place.
These are often temporary and last just a
few years in childhood.
Those are just the benign tumors.
Carcinomas are cancerous tumors found in epithelial
cells.
Sarcomas start off in connective tissue, such
as cartilage and bones.
Leukemia originates in the marrow and generally
mature in the blood or lymph nodes and Blastomas
form from embryonic tissue.
While they all go by different names, many
tumors come from an overgrowth of tissues,
maybe caused by a mistake in DNA.
DNA might be damaged from radiation, tobacco
smoke or other environmental agents, or maybe
it’s just a stroke of luck.
Whatever causes it, this mutation makes the
cell divide uncontrollably, basically making
clones of themselves.
As the cells pile up, a tumor grows.
If it grows big enough it can harm nearby
organs and tissues or sometimes a part of
the tumor can break off and take up residence
in other parts of the body, which is when
cancer metastasizes.
There’s another idea, that stem cells trigger
tumors.
These wonky stem cells drive tumor growth
and just like normal stem cells can give rise
to differentiated cells.
These stem cells are especially good at resisting
treatment like chemotherapy.
Chemotherapy might wipe out those differentiated
cells, but leave the cancer stem cells behind,
so they come back stronger and in greater
numbers.
And I mean chemotherapy is a brutal process,
the first chemotherapy drugs were a derivative
of mustard gas..
But it does have the nifty ability to stop
cell growth.
Which is handy when dealing with runaway cell
growth.
But it can also harm other type of cells that
grow a lot, like hair follicles.
While modern drugs work in other ways, they’re
still pretty nasty.
With the usual side effects of hair loss,
fatigue, nausea, and a knocking out of the
immune system.
Another way we attack tumor cells is through
radiation, where radiation beams are aimed
at a tumor and stop its growth by damaging
DNA.
While the immediate side effects are minimal,
it might feel like a sunburn.
Other long-term effects might be more damaging.
And radiation isn’t 100% effective.
Some tumor cells could get left behind, which
is a problem with surgery too.
Some of these treatments are nasty and painful
and seem to leave the job unfinished.
So why haven’t we come up with anything
better?
Well there’ve been some cool new ideas put
forward recently.
Researchers from Duke University are looking
to treat tumors WITH POLIO.
Polio, a horrible virus, used to run rampant
and kill thousands of people a year and paralyze
thousands more until the introduction of a
vaccine in 1955.
You’d think the world would never want to
see the disease again.
Yet over the past few decades scientists have
reengineered the virus which seems to knock
out a brain tumor’s defenses, allowing the
patient’s immune system to finish the job.
GIVE THE DISEASE DISEASES…
WHOA.
Another new idea might make surgery a little
easier.
Some researchers from the Fred Hutchinson
Cancer Center in Seattle propose injecting
people with scorpion venom.
Alright, sounds crazy I know, but bear with
me.
The venom is injected into the patient's blood
stream, crosses the blood-brain barrier, and
makes its way into the brain tumor.
Tumor Paint, as it’s appropriately called
consists of two parts.
Scorpion venom has to find it’s way to the
prey’s brain to paralyze it.
Turns out that same compound binds really
well the surface of brain tumor cells.
The other part of Tumor Paint lights up under
fluorescent light.
This could be huge.
That way brain surgeons can see the tumor
literally glowing and see where the tumor
stops and the healthy brain tissue starts.
But with any kind of new experimental treatment,
it’s best to be cautious.
Very cautious.
We hear the term CURE FOR CANCER in the news
a lot, and sometimes we never hear another
word about those treatments again.
It’s okay to be optimistic and skeptical
at the same time.
AND REMEMBER: say it with me now…
MORE RESEARCH IS NEEDED.
Can you go one whole day without producing
trash?
Take the #Zerowaste challenge this Tuesday,
April 14th and share your experience with
Seeker!
Go to the first link in the description to
find out more.